vladimir gutierrez comes off his first
big league win when he set the tone in
the sweep against st louis luis uria set
the plate and pitch number one
and urias gets hit and we are underway
in cincinnati and here is avi saeel
garcia
and garcia on the ground and that gets
through and a base hit and moving over
to third will be luis arias as i'll be
able to sneak one through and the
brewers have them on the corners with
two man outs and runners are on the
corners for omar narvaez
and a block has been called
on vladimir gutierrez and the brewers
will get a run without the benefit of a
hit marias comes down the line to score
and the brewers are up one nothing and
there it was saw the little flinch there
before committing to come back anderson
what you see what you get a lot of
sinkers on breaking balls on a chain
jumps hoping to get a lot of ground
balls today he's got the defense behind
him to certainly work for him one away
here's jesse winker
in between ball anderson stabbing try no
winker hustling down the stripe arrives
safe and gets a fist bump from a fan
hustle and this is what happens when
you're having a fantastic year you get
those hits that hmm
good hustle from wink
safe
an old fist pump over there atta boy now
the batter is nick castianos
there's a little topper again it's
anderson flying off the hill spin and
throw low and it squirts free recovers
quickly keeps winker to second
but back-to-back gifts on in-between
balls for the reds two on with one man
out and first ball swinging tyler
stevenson lines one to right and it's
down it rolls by garcia here comes
winker around third to score and
castianos is into third
stevenson the second and the reds have
tied the brewers at one in the first boy
that was a sinking line drive garcia
tried to make a sliding catch
and it hit off his glove but he slowed
it down enough that it didn't roll too
far behind him second and third one out
hard ground ball in between again picked
by adamus sets his feet snaps the throw
in time castellano scores stevenson the
third and motto gets the rbi to put the
reds on top two to one and we head to
the second now the reds two brewers won
travis shaw will lead things off in the
second against gutierrez
swing at the miss the high heat
first k today for gutierrez put that
breaking ball in your mind early you
start thinking about it you elevate a
fastball and that's the result we go to
the bottom of the second and heinemann
draws elite off walk and now the pitcher
vladimir gutierrez will be the hitter
one at two chopped over shaw adamus deep
in the whole long throw
not in time
swing away young man in his third career
start
gutierrez his first career big league
hit
that was 99.5 off the bat
jonathan india has bounced out to third
hard ground ball off the backhand glove
of shaw
through third steam's height of it he
roars home adamus muffs his try gloving
the ball height of it scores three
one reds and we have an injury oh no
shaw goodness
oh no right now the attention is all on
travis shaw who is down
face-first in the dirt and he is in a
lot of pain as his left shoulder went as
his glove went into the ground it looked
like he jammed his
glove into the ground jase peterson is
going to come into this game just saw
him emerge onto the field and travis
says i don't need the cart and he's
walking off with the assistance of scott
behringer and dave yeager runners at
first and second and now it's castianos
runner goes from first that's lined over
third base in
gutierrez scores yellows just now
gathers wave is on for india he scores a
two-run double scolded by castillamos
and john you're telling me this guy is
not
nationally recognized as one of the lead
players in the game and the possible mvp
candidate at this point are you kidding
me
this guy has been so clutch for this
team now threads rookie pitcher vladimir
gutierrez just 31 pitches that's the
fewest by any red starter through their
first three all season narvaez draws the
lead off walk here comes jace peterson
only a piece breaking ball strike three
bounce back from a walk continue to
pound strikes good breaking ball in the
outer half just received word from the
brewers it was a dislocated left
shoulder for travis shaw that was the
diving play from the second inning so
again the update from the clubhouse a
dislocated left shoulder bradley hitting
with runners at first and second one out
swing gonna miss how about that
confidence curve ball down and in and
bradley swings right over top of it he
is down on strikes fourth strike out of
the game so here is pablo reyes pinch
hitting for the pitchers swing and a
miss and down on strikes pablo reyes so
gutierrez strikes out three in the
fourth back to back two out walks from
eric lauer on in relief of brett
anderson tyler stevenson an rvi double
to right
hard ground ball fair down the left
field live
winker around third he scores throw in
cut off castellano scores standing and
stevenson delivers again two out thunder
from the rookie drives in a pair 7-1
reds the brewers have runners at first
and third with one out abaciel garcia is
coming to the plate gutierrez delivers
and avi will lift one into left center
field
scott heinemann is there for out number
two tagging and scoring will be uris
and it's a seven to two ball game and
now omar narvaez hits the runner at
first base there's a little tapper third
base side's gonna be a tough play
gutierrez calls for it picks it up
throws to first in time threw a little
bit into the baseline at first base but
vato able to make the play and the
inning comes to a close vladimir
gutierrez would have stood out once
again the lights are not too bright for
this young man swinging and a miss
breaking ball down and away down on
strikes lauer gutierrez has fans six so
far tonight we will head to the seventh
inning but now you've got your starter
going out for the seventh that's big
time
swing of the miss
vladimir gutierrez pitching in the
seventh inning for the first time of the
show
has seven strikeouts so a two out walk
for yelich man aboard now for a visa
garcia on the ground third base suarez
has it bobbles it momentarily he will go
to india
and the inning is over and the fans rise
to their feet for the rookie vladimir
gutierrez he has given up only two runs
here to these brewers in seven innings
the reds lead
7-2 robertson at third willie adamus the
runner at second keith hembree will come
out of the reds bullpen swing and a miss
struck him out tyrone taylor down on
strikes and the inning is over red's
trying to hold onto his five-run lead
here's daniel vogelback
swinging a high towering drive to right
this one's got a shot if it's fair it is
a fair ball and a home run for daniel
vogelback his fifth of the season boy
did he turn on that fastball up and in
the top hand there stayed tall on the
backside boy and
turned that thing around brewer's making
some noise in the ninth the vogelback
homer the double from yelich garcia's
one for three
today strike three
95 when the outer half elevated two outs
in the night first pitch nick
castellanos measures it up
ball game reds
they even the series with the first
place brewers